e migrants
country you say earlier let's shift over
to the view for their incredible
political analysis of all of this sunny
hustin who is a racist and a communist
uh she also one of the things that
racists and Communists usually don't
want you to be able to do is see things
for yourself so you'll see something and
they'll tell you no no no no you did not
see what you just saw here's Sunny host
telling us that there is no crisis at
the border the Republicans that that
want to be obstreperous want it because
they don't want a Biden win they don't
want Biden to be as successful and his
administration to be as successful as it
can and as it can and and has it as it
has been um the thing that I I I really
think people need to understand about
immigration it's not a crisis it's
something that has been an issue in our
country from the very beginning okay
first off it is a crisis wait can you
just throw back to that for one second
just so I can read the Chiron on the
bottom it said Trump was
can we
forward we're for just a look at the
headline blowing up border talks to
blame Biden yes Donald Trump who's not
the president right now it's of course
it's Donald Trump doing this putting all
of that aside and she's telling you no
there's no border crisis we've always
had a border crisis we're also not
having a border crisis all of that aside
what is going on with that woman's
shoulder pads uh it reminded me of this
yeah that's Carol Bernett that's got to
be 1974 comedy classic right there
wearing the drapes as the shoulder pads
I mean Jesus H people anyway here's
Sunny also confirming that uh fenel is
not really a problem when it comes over
the Border this notion that you know
immigrants are are bringing in all the
fenel into this country we're not that's
that's not true we're talking about drug
cartels that exploit a porta no one is
saying economic migrants to this country
yes you did say earlier there's fenel
bring that's is where the 90% of the
fentel in this country comes across the
southern border where do the opioids
come from that's that's related I love
how Alyssa tries to chime in to say
something saying and she's like would
you just where's your cookie would you
just sit over there no one is saying
every bit of fentanyl is coming over the
border illegally obviously some of it is
homegrown but a huge amount of it is you
know I know someone Loosely who died of
fentol Overdose about two three weeks
ago a young person about 30 years old uh
who from what we understand was not a
fenel user it was an accidental over on
something else it's like the is coming
through the Border it is killing people
so they she doesn't want you to see that
there's a border problem and she doesn't
want to see that fentel is coming over
uh the Border because the Border doesn't
even have a problem uh anyway she's also
very upset there and all of the ladies
of the view are very upset because New
York City which is a sanctuary City you
know it's getting a lot of these
illegals and and the thing is with
progressives they just want to pretend
to be nice not actually be nice when the
hits the fan and I hear this argument a
lot of well Republican border states
actually get more funding so this is
their problem they are so overwhelmed
even with that additional funding then
you have mayor Eric Adams begging for
help from the Biden Administration they
had kids stay home from classrooms for
few days to house migrants and they went
to remote learning what are you say
about a governor AB who's getting a
million dollars to handle the crisis and
he's sending everyone here to the it's
not enough it's not enough money I've
seen the I've been why do he send any
money why doesn't he send any money he's
keeping yes Greg Abbott should send
money to New York City New York City
which has some of the highest taxes in
the world right because New York you're
paying New York state tax which is
basically one or two top two highest
taxes in the nation and then New York
City tax which is also high so
everyone's fleeing New York Greg you
hear her Greg Abbot got a million bucks
Greg Abbot got a million bucks from the
federal government why don't he send
some cash it's so freaking insane but
you must understand these people have
infected the entire whatever
intellectual piece of leftism there was
it has decimated all of these people
they're brains are like are like Roar
Shack paintings they have been
completely obliterated and you could
look at them and you can analyze it
however you see
fit